JOANNA SMITH: Modern
Android devices
have potentially lots of apps
with background services.
And this is exactly
as it should be.
But it can be problematic
when each of the services
just runs willy-nilly all
over the user's processor.
What we see happening on devices
in a low memory situation
is that there is often a number
of background services running,
but there isn't enough
memory for all of them.
And when this happens
the operating system
must swap a lot of
processes in and out
of RAM, known as
memory thrashing.
And this reduces the
overall system performance,
which manifests as
poor performance
for the app the user is actually
trying to use-- not great.
So why do so many background
services trigger at once?
Often it is in response
to an implicit broadcast.
An implicit broadcast
is a trigger
that declares an event instead
of calling a specific app,
meaning that the reasonable use
case of passing some data along
to another app to do a
task for you is lost.
Instead, we have the
madness of a single app
standing up and shouting that
it just did something cool.
Who wants to come see?
Even worse though, most
apps have a static receiver
declared in their manifest
to listen for these, which
means the app isn't even
running when it gets
the broadcast for this event.
So it is woken up solely for
the opportunity to respond.
And the worst case is
an app being woken up
to look at the event
and then deciding
it wasn't interested
after all, and we just
wasted several
precious RAM cycles.
The most common instance of this
is with connectivity change.
On some devices, we've seen
more than 40 apps woken up
as a result of this broadcast.
And when this broadcast
is sent frequently,
it could mean hundreds of
wake-ups in a few minutes,
crippling device performance.
So what's the solution?
Well, we're removing
connectivity change as well as
a few other
broadcasts we commonly
see causing this problem.
Because any one app
isn't a bad actor,
but many apps doing the
same not-so-great thing
often translates to an
overwhelming problem
that only the
platform can solve.
So let's talk about
these changes.
First, connectivity
change will no longer
wake apps that are
targeting in if you
declared a static
receiver in the manifest.
If your app is already
running and you're
registered your
receiver, you can still
receive this broadcast, but
you will not wake up for it.
Now, if you do
have some work that
needs to be done based on
the connectivity change
and regardless of
whether app is running,
you'll want to schedule a job
with JobScheduler or Firebase
JobDispatcher for the
network conditions
you truly care about instead
of passively listening,
and waking, and then checking to
see if the connectivity change
was the right change for you.
And when your app uses
JobScheduler and everyone
else's apps start
using it, the system
can batch all of those
jobs, leading to a much more
stable situation overall.
Another situation is with new
NEW_PICTURE and NEW_VIDEO.
This is a critical
user experience moment
because slowing down the
camera by waking all these apps
can destroy the camera
experience causing users
to miss the moment.
These broadcasts aren't
sent by the system,
but by apps, such as Camera.
So we're removing it entirely.
Know that these
two changes are not
specific for apps
targeting NuGet.
All apps on a device
that is running NuGet
will no longer be
able to receive them
regardless of which
version you're targeting.
Both broadcasts have been
fully deprecated in API 24.
The alternative
here is to again use
JobScheduler, which has been
updated to consider content
provider changes as a trigger.
We're trying our best
to move to a world that
is dynamic without
passive receivers
claiming processor
time for work that
should be done in a better way.
So check out the Docs
for code you can copy
and paste into your
own app and have
some fun getting to know
JobScheduler's updated options.
But most importantly, just
continue to build better apps.
[MUSIC PLAYING]